l'autre thème majeur du voyage au
pakistan de françois mitterrand a été le
conflit du cachemire pour l'instant
monsieur mitterrand et madame benazir
buttho se sont contentés d'en discuter
hier encore des soldats pakistanais et
indiens ont échangé des coups de feu
dans cette région il y a eu des blessés
le cachemire c'est un état de l'inde le
seul état de l'un va avoir une
population de musulmans
le cachemire veut donc son indépendance
et le pakistan le soutien au brier de l'
air france brille ses reportages au
cachemire
niché dans les contreforts de l'himalaya
la zad cachemire le cachemire libre
placé sous administration pakistanaise
depuis 1949 est à la fois paisible et
inhospitalier sur plus de 700 km soldats
indiens et pakistanais se font face
depuis 40 ans des centaines de postes
frontières sont disséminés comme celui
là sur la ligne de cessez-le-feu qui
suit la rivière à cet endroit dans la
solitude de ses positions souvent
inaccessibles l'hiver les soldats n'ont
qu'une mission prouver à ceux d'en face
que le terrain n'est pas à prendre
mais le cachemire indien s'est enflammé
à nouveau la province musulmane seule
terre d'islam dans l'immensité hindous
réclame le scrutin d'autodétermination
prévu il ya déjà quatre décennies par
les nations unies solidarité politique
et surtout fraternité religieuse le
pakistan tout entier s'embrase à son
tour
osant parfois même envisager une
nouvelle guerre avec new delhi n'a
jamais su vivre en paix avec ses voisins
on l'a vu en chine au bangladesh ou au
sri lanka et c'est là qu'est le danger à
chaque fois qu'un peuple s'est battu
pour son droit à la liberté
l'inde a toujours trouvé un prétexte
qu'ils préféraient l'affrontement
tangible de la crise qui se nouent au
cachemire les réfugiés commencent
d'affluer depuis le début de l'année
dans la province pakistanaise de nuit
pour éviter le tir des soldats indiens
il traverse par petits groupes montagne
des ravines ceux là sont arrivés au
matin épuisé gelé quelques uns pieds nus
dans l'hiver glacial ils sont une
vingtaine de personnes une même famille
à avoir choisi de quitter l'inde par
peur des représailles et de la guerre
pour tout bagage les vêtements qu'ils
portent et l'espoir de connaître un jour
à cachemire libre et musulmans je crois
que maintenant nous approchons de la
solution 40 ans sont déjà passés les
cachemires et n'auront pas à attendre
encore aussi longtemps
en tout cas la rue semble avoir déjà
perdu patience comme ici à nous à farah
bad la capitale du cachemire
les manifestations sont désormais
quotidiennes au pakistan aux fidèles la
est le plus grand la foule menacent de
lancer la guerre sainte contre le voisin
indien
explosion de haine et de sectarisme
religieux
encouragés par le régime qui risque
pourtant d'en perdre le contrôle
on croit maintenant il sait qu'une
véritable guerre la troisième éclate
entre l'inde et le pakistan pour la
possession du cachemire
en tout cas le consensus national qui
s'est fait sur la situation pourrait
bien permettre au gouvernement bouton de
restaurer son autorité et de retrouver
sa popularité